Hôm nay, 2.8 năm, ngày 2020, các quan cạnh rất đều tra công an tình quảng chỉ đã ra quyết định hợi tổ hủ an.
Hợi tổ bị cân và rất lệ bắt tạm giang đời với nỗi nọc đạo.
Xin nămu hình chính xam chính mi mốt, chú tại sát kinh định tình quảng chỉ,
tạm chú phường an 2, tình phố đả nắng về hình vì cứ tại sản tạm chứ sự giống trải phép phục khi quân dụng và giết người.
Chứ đó, vào khoảng 14 hong qua, đạo tuyên xe tổ của anh BTS, chú tại phường hoặc hánh, tình phố đả nắng,
để về sát kinh định, khoảng chỉ, dải quyết mộn thống dài đi.
Sau khi chờ đạo về tại sát kinh phố, khoảng chỉ, khi đạo nói với anh BTS là mựa xe chạy đi việc dương.
Anh S không đồng ý và xe ra khai phá, đạo đã sự giúp dự trế mang theo bánh anh S từ vong và giấu xác tại phu quân kinh kia chạm,
tục tôn liên hóa, xác kinh phố, xó đó, đạo được kinh xe về nhà bố mẹ vộ tại sát kinh định.
Có thủ trong sát kinh định, có thủ trong sát, yêu cầu được gặp vợ con.
Này sát khi tiếp nhận thông tin, lực lượng công an đã nhìn trong sự khai các bị pháp mi vụ,
và đọc, tiếp phục lưới tượng, đến khoảng bỗng dự hông này, mưỡng học đạo đã tự vình ra nộ xung và ra tự tụ.